- We have a photo of you here.
Can you tell me what's going on here?
I need to know this photo.
- Oh, yeah.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly and Jennifer laughing)
- [Jennifer] Yeah,
- [Kelly] I mean your hair-
- [Jennifer] So that's me
- [Kelly] You're so Texan.
- [Jennifer] That's me
in all my Texas glory.
Uh huh, yeah, and I was going to
a New Kids on the Block concert.
- Of course.
- In a fringe jacket
that my mom made me,
with my big Texas, y'know, Aqua Net hair.
And feeling myself, like I was really,
I mean I was really
feeling myself that day.
And so I went to the
concert, and it was wonderful
because it was New Kids on the Block,
and I had the Joey McIntyre sheets
like all the girls in
the world at the time.
And I'd sleep on the pillow
case with his face on it,
and just like love him.
And I got to go backstage
(Kelly and audience laughing)
right, like, at the back entrance,
and scream with all the girls,
and I like reached out, like "Joey!",
y'know like (screams).
And I reached out, and got
to touch him for a second,
and he like, gave me
this like terrible look,
like "crazy little girl get
off of me" kind of thing.
And it broke my heart for years.
- Aw...
- And then I got to meet
him later as a grown up,
and I told him that story,
and he gave me this gigantic hug.
And he was like, "I'm so sorry.
It was such a crazy time."
And he like fully just like
sewed up this little tiny part of my heart
that had always been broken
by the New Kids on the Block.
And I just love him for
it, and it was so cute.
- Aw! That's amazing; that's so cool
that you had that
experience to walk up to him
and be like, "So, listen here.
You broke me."
- I was like, I hold
onto things apparently.
(Kelly and Jennifer laughing)
- Well no it is funny what
happens when you're a kid.
What does stick. It's insane.
Did you perform in Texas as a kid?
I did all the time.
So did you do that?
- Oh yeah, I was um, I performed
a lot at Livestock shows.
- Oh my gosh. That's amazing!
- So like the farmer would come out,
and be like, "(mumbling)
pig soldier, y'know,
Lucy what's-it."
And then he did like a,
"Here's Jennifer Love!"
And I would go out in
my little, like, y'know,
cowboy boots and fringe
jacket that my mom had made,
with the big hair.
And yeah, I was like the
performer at Livestock shows.
I did it for years.
And then, y'know, like some, I don't know,
fairs and stuff like that.
It was great; I loved it.
- Oh no, I did fairs too.